PAUL FREEDMAN:Gregory
of Tours.
Here we enter further into
a stranger world.
As I told you at the outset of
the course, it begins fairly
reasonably, as if it's another
history course with great
powers, states, recognizable
theories of government, and
practices of government.
Now we're into what certainly
seems like a combination of
thugs and miracles.
And I hope that you'll see, if
you haven't seen already, that
far from being contradictory,
thugs and miracles go
together, historically.
We've already entered
into a somewhat
strange realm with Procopius.
Procopius' Secret History
certainly is a strange story,
with strange theories of
causality and a strange cast
of characters.
But it is narrated in a
high classical style.
Insofar as the pieces are a bit
jumbled, it's because it
wasn't completed.
But as you will have seen, if
you think about Procopius, he
is easy to read because
he's leading you on.
He has several points to make,
and he makes them with great
rhetorical power.
His Secret History is
in the classical
tradition of the invective.
And in a way, we are better
able to understand this
because our own political
discourse has gotten much more
crude and extreme in the last
thirty years or so.
So political invective,
historical invective,
stylistically well - composed,
is not unfamiliar to us.
But Gregory of Tours is.
In a way, I've cheated by giving
you the assignment from
this edition of Alexander
Murray, because he rearranges
and excerpts things.
The full work is much fatter,
and Murray tries to make the
story fairly coherent with
headings, grouping things
together, explaining a little
what's going on, to say
nothing of the nice maps
and genealogical
tables in the back.
But that loses some of
the random quality--
or seemingly random quality--
that Gregory has.
He has this funny way of seeming
to move from one thing
to another without any
kind of transition or
for no apparent purpose.
So in one of the little sections
of Book 3 that's not
in Murray, he's telling us
now we have a miracle.
"There lived at the city of
Langres, Saint Gregory, that
priest of God famed far and
wide for his miracles and
virtuous deeds.
While I am talking about this
bishop, I thought you would
like me to tell you something of
the town of Dijon, where he
spent his youth." Well,
wait a minute.
Did I ask about Dijon?
Do I even know where Dijon is?
Weren't we talking about
Theuderic and Chlothar and
their feud?
How have we gotten into, first
of all, a story of a saint,
and second, a little travelogue
about Dijon?
So that is Gregory.
You've got to like this.
And I think we are better
equipped you, especially--
because we're not so linear
as we used to be.
You know, magazines used to be
just a set of articles, and
that was it.
And then about twenty years
ago, they started just
breaking up into these
miscellaneous things with
little observations, and here's
what's happening in
Wichita Falls.
But, you know, I don't
live there.
But so what?
You know, food festival in
Colorado Springs, and what
about this train trip
in New Zealand?
Well, I'm not in New
Zealand, either.
You know what I mean.
This kind of little offers
from all over the place,
little possibilities,
observations, wit and wisdom.
This is the experience
of modern media.
So I wouldn't say that Gregory
is ahead of his time, but I
don't want you to
complain to me--
well, I mean, you can, but
I will not be incredibly
sympathetic with, "Wait, I don't
know where this stops
and begins." Or "Wait, are we
responsible for Theodebert
versus Theuderic?" The answer to
that is "No." I'm not going
to give you a short answer about
which of these names is
best for your cat.
PROFESSOR: Or, you
know, name at least five
of Clovis' grandchildren.
But the rhythm of this, the
power of these rulers, their
thuggery or their violence,
their internecine violence,
their respect for miracles,
Gregory's sense of God's
intervention, is very
important to grasp.
And we will talk about the
actual historical importance
of this people that Gregory
chronicles, the Franks.
The chief thing about the Franks
from Gregory's point of
view is that they are
Catholic Christians.
They never--
unlike almost all other of the
invaders of the Roman Empire--
they never go through a
period of Arianism.
Clovis converts from paganism
to regular-guy Roman
Christianity.
And from Clovis' point of view,
that is what is of chief
importance--
from Gregory's point of view.
Gregory of Tours, the author,
is writing in
the late sixth century.
So around the same time,
a few decades later,
perhaps, than Procopius.
Gregory lived from 539 to 594.
In his time, there was still a
distinction between Romans and
barbarians, and Gregory
was very conscious of
himself as a Roman.
He was from a distinguished
Roman senatorial family.
Note that he uses the word
"senatorial," a rank of the
Roman Empire, even though the
Roman Empire, from our point
of view, certainly hasn't
existed for a
hundred years or so.
He notes that eighteen bishops
of Tours, his see--
of the eighteen bishops of
Tours, all but five were
related to him.
That shows you that being a
bishop was a Roman office, an
elite Roman office, even in
the barbarian period.
And also you'll see that
Gregory's behavior shows us
that the bishops, to some
extent, have inherited Roman
offices and Roman
responsibilities.
They are part of the government,
and in a sense,
opposed to the more brutal
aspects of Merovingian,
Frankish government.
Gregory became bishop of Tours
in 573, and so he was bishop
for twenty-one years.
He probably began writing
this book--
which is actually just called
The Book of the Histories--
shortly after his election.
So he's writing in the
570s to early 590s.
He begins Book 1, which we
haven't read, with the story
of creation and takes it to the
death of Saint Martin, the
great patron of Tours.
And then he begins, properly
speaking, with at least the
legendary history of the dynasty
of the Frankish kings,
the descendants of a certain
Merovech, hence Merovingians,
the name for this dynasty.
Gregory also wrote a
number of saints'
lives and martyr stories.
He was very attached
to Saint Martin.
At one point, in one of those
episodes not in Murray, he
says, "If you celebrate the
feast of Saint Martin
faithfully, you will gain the
protection of the saintly
bishop in this world
and the next." And
indeed, that's very important.
Remember when Clovis--
and this is in Murray,
on the page 17--
when Clovis decides he's going
to attack the Visigoths?
Now, he says he's attacking them
because he can't stand to
have Arians occupying Gaul,
which is on page 16.
"Then Clovis said to his men,
'I take it very badly that
these Arians hold
part of Gaul.
With God's help, let's go and
conquer them, and bring the
land under His authority." And
a soldier seizes hay from a
poor peasant.
This is just the way
soldiers are.
They need that hay, the civilian
has the hay, they're
on the march, he grabs it.
But this peasant is on the lands
of Saint Martin, of land
belonging to Tours.
And the king, thug though he is,
has issued an order saying
the troops were not
to take anything
except fodder and water.
And in fact, sort of
hay is fodder.
Nevertheless, "the king, who
quicker than it takes to say
it, had him put to the sword."
Guy, you've made a mistake.
And he's killed.
And Clovis says of this
incident, "How shall there be
hope of victory, if we offend
the blessed Martin?"
So you've got to take seriously,
if you want to call
it superstition, fine.
But the Frankish rulers are at
least amenable to influence
from the priests, bishops,
guardians of the saints.
And notice--
because we're going to come
back to this a lot.
You're going to see it
everywhere in the early Middle
Ages, post-Roman world--
the saint is not dead.
It's not like Martin is some
just kind of presence, the
way, you know, the happy dead
who are indifferent to us.
Martin is an angry saint,
or potentially angry.
In fact, all saints worth
anything in the early Middle
Ages are very touchy.
If you seize hay from land
belonging to their church,
they'll strike you dead, or they
will see to it that you
die in battle.
And Gregory is indeed full of
incidents in which holy
figures, alive or dead, have
this kind of ability to
mobilize supernatural power.
What is his historical model?
I mean if Procopius, in The
Wars, models himself after
Thucydides, and if in the
Secret History he models
himself after a tradition
of invective, what
is Gregory's model?
We don't really know
his sources.
One reason why he's so important
is that for an awful
lot of the history of the
Merovingians, he's about all
we have. And although
disorganized--
quote "disorganized"--
from our point of view,
he's very detailed.
But he does have a model, and
that model is the Bible, the
Hebrew Bible or the
Old Testament.
If you read the Old Testament,
it is, as I think I've said
before, full of violence
and full of miracles.
And they are sort
of jumbled up.
The hand of God is very
apparent in the Bible.
And generally speaking, those
who disobey God are punished.
The same is true in Gregory,
although the hand of God is a
little more mediated by
those holy figures--
saints, hermits, bishops--
that we just discussed.
There is a little bit more of
a priestly power, but then
again, the Bible has figures
like Moses, who are able to--
Joshua, who's able
to stop the sun.
Priestly figures, indeed.
So from Gregory's point of view,
there is a continuity
between biblical history and
the history of his times.
He describes, in the prologue
to Book 2--
which is not in Murray--
that his plan is to describe the
holy deeds of the saints
and the way in which
whole races
of people were butchered.
OK, you got a problem
with that?
At least the second part
we all know is
what history's about.
It's the first that's a
little tough, the holy
deeds of the saints.
And particularly as they're
not off on the side.
The popular imagination loves
what might be called "holy
deeds of the saints." If you
look at gossip magazines of
the lower sort, or kind of
internet folklore, weird
births, raining frogs, space
aliens all sorts of
supernatural events clog them.
Along with stars--
that is, movie stars or media
stars gossip, and a little bit
of history, a little bit
of current events.
This is not so dissimilar,
in that sense.
Gregory is both a historian
and a political actor.
He does not have either the
luxury or the irrelevance of
most historians now, who
sit comfortably--
or in my case, not very
comfortably, since I'm in an
unrenovated office-- but
comfortably enough.
PROFESSOR: In universities and
maybe comment
on what's going on.
No.
Gregory is very, very involved
with the Merovingian rulers.
And he has to display courage.
He refuses to surrender
fugitives who have sought
asylum in his cathedral
when they are
demanded by royal officials.
He defends his fellow bishop,
Praetextatus, who was accused
by the king of treason.
You'll be reading about
this for next week.
He'll have arguments, again in
your reading for next week,
with the king himself about the
Trinity, and has to defend
himself against the charge
of slandering the king's
concubine--
really, here, the word
"concubine" isn't quite right,
because these kings are
kind of polygamists--
against the king's favorite,
Fredegund.
And Gregory is tried
for defaming her.
He resists taxes.
He seems to have been
a small man.
He suffered ill health, or at
least he took an inordinate
interest in his own health.
He was a great believer in
potions made with dust from
the relics and tombs
of holy men.
A medicine prescribed as potio
de pulvere sepulchre, a potion
made from sepulcher dust. But
it's got to be of the right
kind of people.
What is his attitude
towards the Franks?
I've said he regards them
as thugs and barbarians.
But at the same time, he regards
them as the people of
Israel, reborn as a race
favored by God.
The Franks claimed--
or at least their spokespersons,
their learned
spokespersons--
claimed to be descended from
refugees of fallen Troy.
Thus, like the Romans.
In fact, we don't really know
anything about them until they
appear in Roman sources
in the third century.
We don't know what held
them together.
We're back to this problem
of ethnogenesis.
Do they speak a common
language?
Do they just travel in
a pack together?
Do they regard themselves
as a people
having a common ancestor?
Well, we don't really know.
Constantine's father, at the
end of the third century,
dealt with them and settled
them in what's now the Low
Countries, Holland
and Belgium.
They were federati, which you
remember means allied armies
of the Empire.
They served the Empire actually
fairly loyally in the
early fourth century, and they
became rich doing so.
We don't really know if the
supposed ancestors of Clovis--
Merovech himself,
for example--
were real or legendary.
Supposedly, Merovech is
Clovis' grandfather.
We don't know if he existed.
But we do know something about
his father, Chilperic.
Well, it's a chalkless day, so
the guy's name is Chilperic.
C-H-I-L-P-E-R-I-C. We know about
him because his grave
was dug up in the seventeenth
century.
Unfortunately, all the stuff
that was in his grave, most of
it was stolen in 1831.
But drawings had been made
before that, and they show
that he owned or was buried with
a cloak embroidered with
cicadas, a crystal
globe, a gold
bracelet, a Frankish amulet.
His horse's--we assume it was
his horse's head buried with
him, and it was covered
with precious metal.
He was also buried with
100 gold coins
and 200 silver ones.
And a signet ring that shows
him with long hair, and the
ring is inscribed--
in case we wondered
who this was--
King Chilperic.
The long hair is important.
It is a symbol of the power
of these rulers.
It is a kind of dynastic
charisma.
And indeed, one of the best
books about these rulers, by
an English historian is called
Long Haired Kings.
What is all this stuff?
The stuff that's buried
with him?
A lot of it comes
from Byzantium.
A lot of this would have been
bribes or goodwill gestures by
the emperors interested in
keeping some nominal loyalty
on the part of the barbarian
tribes in the collapse of the
Western Empire.
Clovis succeeded Chilperic,
his father, as the head of
this federated tribe of now
a nonexistent empire.
All that remains of the Empire
is a Roman commander.
Remember we mentioned, in the
life of Saint Antoninus of
Noricum that an emissary was
sent from the Roman army to
try to get paid and discovered
that the
Empire no longer existed.
That there was nobody
to pay them.
Syagrius, S-Y-A-G-R-I-U-S, is
a little bit like this.
He's a general in northern Gaul
of the Roman Empire, and
now that the Roman
Empire ceases to
exist, he's on his own.
And he is a rival for Clovis,
and one of the first targets
of his expansion.
Gregory calls him "king of the
Romans." What does that mean?
Rome didn't have king's.
We don't really know
what title he used.
We have no documents
from him, no coins.
Probably Byzantium, the eastern
Roman Empire, didn't
like him, and probably they
supported Clovis.
At any rate, he was killed in
486, and Clovis' next target
of expansion was the Visigoths,
those Arians that
Gregory tells us about in the
passage that I mentioned to
you just a little while ago.
What kind of personality
does Clovis have?
Have we met his type before?
Is there any difference?
Anybody have a sense of him?
How does he strike you?
Just another one of these
characters of the early Middle
Ages, or is there's
something unusual?
STUDENT: Killing off everybody,
including his
family members?
PROFESSOR: He kills off
everybody, including
his family members.
Yeah, yeah.
This is, unfortunately,
not unusual.
And why?
STUDENT: He doesn't want
any family member
to lay claim to--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
wouldn't you think he'd be
dynastically conscious?
Constantius, the Emperor in the
fourth century, did the
same thing.
Only his nephews, Gallus and
Julian, survived, and indeed,
Julian defeated him.
Is he, then, just the same kind
of violent character, or
randomly violent character?
Is there a plan besides
expansion?
At least in Gregory's
portrayal?
STUDENT: Christianity.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
STUDENT: Christianity,
forcing conversion.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
He is Christian.
Christianity.
He doesn't force conversion, but
he himself converts, and
his men with him.
We know his piety even before
the conversion, because of
this incident with the silver
liturgical bowl, or ewer.
Right?
On page seven and
eight, in 227?
STUDENT: The story
seems dubious.
PROFESSOR: The story
The story being that they
plundered this church, the
Church of Rheims The bishop asks
Clovis for this silver
bowl to be returned.
Clovis says he's got to consult
his men, because they
have a kind of booty
splitting muster.
Notice that this shows a
certain leader/follower
relationship, rather than
absolute ruler/follower
relationship.
Clovis says to his men something
on the order of "me
hardies," or "my good men." "Me
hardies" maybe is a little
too pirate-like.
"So," he begins.
"So I want that ewer to return
it to the Church in addition
to my share of half." And one
soldier says, "No, you get
half of that, just like
everything else.
Takes out his axe, one of the
important weapons of the
Franks, and splits the
silver thing in half.
And Clovis doesn't do anything
immediately.
In a later muster, he says to
the guy, recognizing him, your
kit is a mess. "Your shield, you
call that a shield?" And
he knocks something down, and as
the guy picks it up, Clovis
takes up his own axe and
splits the guy's head.
Saying as he does so, "Thus
you did to my ewer, or my
basin, in Soissons."
Yeah, dubious story, but
interesting because it shows
both the power of the ruler and
some limitations, as well
as his type of piety.
Power--
actually, you know, the
president of the United States
actually does have the
power to kill people.
We've seen it in action.
Though at a distance and under
certain, very special
circumstances.
But basically, it takes a
certain kind of ruler to be
able to kill someone
outright like that.
It still happens, but we're
talking about people like
Qaddafi or despots.
So certainly, as with killing
the guy who stole the hay from
Saint Martin's land, Clovis is
following a certain set of
leadership tips that basically
amounts to winning by maximum
intimidation, I think
it's fair to say.
But he's got to do this in a
careful way, because his
followers are very important.
They are powerful.
He does depend on them, and he's
got to give at least the
impression of being the leader
of a band and not the kind of
ruler of the state that we might
be more familiar with.
Leadership is personal but
there's a kind of tribal
sense, or tribal sense
of democracy.
The other thing about the story,
of course, is once
again the controversy is over
piety towards things of the
Church, even before Clovis has,
at least according to
Gregory, officially converted.
It's not that you should be
nice to the Church because
it's good to be a nice person.
It's that you've got to be nice
to the Church because the
Church is in command of
supernatural weapons that will
overcome the weapons
of this world.
The supernatural interpenetrates
the physical
or historical at every point
in Gregory's narrative.
So the overwhelming fact for
Gregory, as I said before, is
that he is orthodox, or Catholic
i.e., not Arian.
Clovis is, in Gregory's eyes,
the new Constantine.
Someone who has miraculously
been turned, thuggish though
he is-- and Constantine
was, as well--
to advance God's work.
Of course, Gregory regards him
as a barbarian, and he shows
him as a barbarian.
He portrays him honestly, or
at least unflatteringly.
As was said, he murdered
his family.
And then moreover, if you
remember on pages 19 and 20,
he pretends to be really sorry
that he can't find anybody
that he's related to.
He's searching findmyfamily.com
for a
genealogy or high school
classmates.
Anybody who could
be his friend.
But in fact, he is
just searching
them out to kill them.
And he's got all sorts of tricks
to kill his relatives.
Nevertheless, in the same
chapter that describes his
trick on Cloderic, Gregory tells
us, "Having aquired the
kingdom of Sigibert and its
treasury, he also received
those people under
his dominion.
For daily the Lord laid his
enemies low under his hand and
increased his kingdom, because
he walked before Him with an
upright heart and did what was
pleasing in His sight." Right?
This is just after Clovis, after
the death of Sigibert,
calls all the people together,
says, "I don't know what
happened, but the sons of
Sigibert seem to have died as
they were showing my
envoy's treasure.
Here's my proposal, make me
king." And they say, "Oh, OK.
Great, yeah.
Step on the shield and we'll
lift you up, just like the
Roman emperors."
Is Gregory a comedian?
Or is he saying--
and I think this is more
likely, although he is
hilarious to read.
I mean, I hope he's
amused you.
I hope while you were cursing
me for giving you this
assignment, or at least praying
to some saints to
strike me dumb or erupt in boils
or probably not anything
very strong, like you'll notice
that occasionally
people lose their intestines
when they go to the bathroom.
Probably not.
The heretic Arias, for example,
and others who betray
the saints.
Anyway, whatever curses you
were summoning up to me, I
hope you actually
found this fun.
This course is fun, as I think
I told you way back in the
beginning of September.
So apart from the fun angle,
people are instruments of the
Lord, and they walk in the sight
of the Lord even if they
are not themselves
good people.
The Lord makes use of
instruments, of
people who are forceful.
It's important to be forceful.
If Clovis was a nice guy-- and
we'll see, and have already
seen some examples of rulers
who were nice, often
intellectual, and ineffectual.
Gregory prefers effectual with
some violent touches to
ineffectual, because being a
ruler is a hard job in a
barbarian world, in
a fallen world.
Gregory, in this sense,
is like Augustine.
The world has fallen.
The world is corrupt.
There are no good
people in power.
And if they are in power, it is
either unusual or they're
not going to be in
power for long.
Therefore, it is important
to be violent.
It is important to be able to
intimidate your troops.
It is important to seek out
those who would oppose you.
And if they've got
to be killed,
they've got to be killed.
The reason for this is that the
work of the Lord has to be
advanced, according to Gregory,
and the Church has to
be protected.
For Gregory is exemplifying what
I said would happen as
predicted by Saint Augustine.
The Empire might cease, but
the Church would not.
The Church would deal with
whatever successors came up,
be they Arian, or
preferably not.
Be they cultivated, or more
likely barbarian.
And as barbarian leaders
go, Clovis and his
sons were not so bad.
We're not really sure how
Clovis converted.
Because Gregory is invested in
a story that likens Clovis to
Constantine, we have the
same kind of thing.
Before a battle, he makes a deal
with God that if he wins
the battle, he will convert.
We don't really know if he was
converted before this battle
in 494, as Gregory reports, or
maybe in a battle against the
Visigoths in 506.
But it doesn't really matter.
It's very important that
the Arians be defeated.
He's got a story that's not in
Murray, in Book 2, Chapter 23,
in which an Arian bishop
named Cryola.
C-R-Y-O-L-A. Cryola,
not crayola.
Cryola.
Cryola is angry because he
sees the Catholic bishops
performing miracles all
over the place.
So he pays a guy to pretend to
be blind, and then to greet
him as he comes to Church, and
beg him to heal his sight, and
then to say, "Oh my gosh,
I've been healed.
I can see.
But God punishes this by making
him actually blind, at
this point.
And then the guy, very helpfully
from the Catholic
point of view, said oh,
I wasn't blind.
This evil bishop, Cryola, bribed
me in order to pretend
to be blind, but now God and
his saints, Saint Martin in
particular, have punished me."
And so that it takes a
Catholic bishop to heal
him back to sight.
So this is Gregory's attitudes
towards the Arians.
On the other hand, he does
report that the Franks
besieged Saragossa.
This is on pages 41, 42.
The Spanish city of Saragossa.
They've gotten that
far in their
attacks on the Visigoths.
But the Arians were able
to fight them off.
"They circled the walls carrying
the tunic of Saint
Vincent and singing psalms.
With the women dressed in
black, their hair
hanging loose,
covered in ashes, lamented.
Seeing the situation,
Theodebert returned.
He gave up the siege." The
Arians may be heretics, but
they've got the tunic
of Saint Vincent.
And the power of that relic is
so great that even in the
hands of miscreants, it's
not to be opposed.
Saint Vincent, a very important
saint and the patron
of Saragossa.
So the Arians are fakes, but
they are not completely
without spiritual
power, either.
And this is a kind of universe
in which there are natural and
supernatural forces.
And it's not that one trumps the
other, exactly, but that
they both have to be
taken into account.
So, Clovis consolidates a large
kingdom in most of what
would become France.
Roman Gaul, medieval France.
France named after this
group, the Franks.
The Visigoths now were pushed
out into Spain and just that
part of France bordering
on Spain.
Clovis received the favor
of the Church
because he was Catholic.
His conversion, let's say around
500, is ninety years
before the Visigoths
become Catholic.
And this aids him greatly,
because the Church is in
possession of learned people,
financial resources, and
spiritual power.
So we follow the Franks--
and we will follow them up
through Charlemagne and his
successors--
because they are successful,
and because their own
self-consciousness is as the
rightful rulers of the former
Western Empire.
A claim that in various
generations is more or less of
a reality and that is by no
means inevitable, but is
something that they will
eventually make good on.
For the time being, Clovis
considers himself a
representative of the Byzantine
Empire, but a
representative who very
conveniently doesn't have to
do anything.
The Byzantine Emperor sends
him the title of consul.
He's very pleased at this, but
it doesn't bind him, really.
So much for Clovis.
Establishment of Frankish
hegemony.
The prominence of the Franks
in the post-Roman West. The
first Catholic people among
the barbarian invaders.
Now we turn briefly
to his sons.
He divided his kingdom equally,
and you have a map in
the back that shows the division
of the realm under
Clovis' sons.
Chlothar, Childebert, Chlodomer,
and Theuderic.
This practice of division
is dangerous.
It is usually a better idea to
give it to one son, because
then you don't divide
the kingdom.
On the other hand, if you have
four sons who are all
militarily competent,
they're going to
fight with each other.
And in fact they fight with
each other, as Gregory
describes in Book
3, even though
they've been given divisions.
The violence of Clovis' sons is
crude and even ludicrous.
So for example, this awful
incident of Chlodomer's sons
being protected by Clovis' queen
Chlothild And her sons,
the boys' uncles, Chlothar and
Theodoric, invite the boys to
come for a visit.
And Clotilde, who seems rather
credulous, says, "Great idea!"
Once they are in the power of
these two brothers, who of
course like Clovis want to
kill their relatives,
particularly their younger
relatives, they send a sword
and a pair of scissors, right?
"Which will it be," the
messenger asks the queen.
"Cut off their hair or kill
them?" Cutting off their hair
will symbolize that they're no
longer eligible for rulership.
And it may lead to them being
put away in a monastery or
something like that, but
they're taking early
retirement.
They're twelve, fourteen years
old, but they've had it.
And Chlothild is so angry, at
least according to Gregory,
that he says she'd rather
see them die.
And then they kill them.
They kill them in this ludicrous
way, because one of
them gets cold feet, and the
other is furious and takes up
the sword, and just
kills them.
Even though they're begging.
I mean, it's a rather
gruesome scene.
Meanwhile, in a scene that we
haven't got in Murray's
edition, Theuderic attempts
to kill Chlothar.
He invites him, and he's got men
waiting to ambush him, but
the cloth isn't low
enough down.
They're sort of behind a
partition, a cloth partition,
but Chlothar can
see their feet.
And so he kind of turns
back and starts to
walk out of the hall.
And then Theuderic says, "No,
no, no, I just invited you to
give you a gift." And he gives
him a silver goblet or
something like that.
So, Chlothar escapes from this,
but Theuderic is so
angry at having been tricked
that he then sends a messenger
saying it was a mistake to
give back the goblet.
So, I mean, these guys,
what can I say?
Yet beneath the barbarian acts
is a society that is still
being governed fairly closely.
There is a fairly sophisticated
administration still.
There's a gold coinage,
which takes a lot of
resources to maintain.
These rulers are collecting
taxes, and they are collecting
taxes according to
written records.
There's public land.
There's revenue from land
belonging to the king.
The kings are reasonably
conscientious about the
appointment of bishops.
What is Gregory's attitude
towards these sons of Clovis?
He certainly portrays
them as fratricidal.
Nevertheless, on page 26, he
tells us that the brothers
were endowed with great courage
and had considerable
military resources.
Once again, their power
is directed more for
good than for bad.
And a lot of their power
for bad is merely
directed at each other.
He considers them, in other
words, appropriate rulers for
savage times.
At one point, two of
the brothers make
war against a third.
Specifically, Childebert and
Theuderic against Chlothar.
Chlothar is the guy who has just
been depicted by Gregory
as the tough one, the one who
killed the two nephews.
He's also an adulterer.
And yet, faced with
his brother's
armies, he prays to God.
And his mother, Queen
Chlothild,
prays to Saint Martin.
So powerful are these prayers
that the two brothers are
unsuccessful.
A hailstorm pelts their troops,
spares Chlothar, and
Chlothar is victorious.
The brothers do not succeed
in dislodging him.
Here then, we have the power
of the Merovingians and the
limitations on that power.
The limitations are partly
military, partly that of
fratricidal intrigue, of
people getting killed.
But they're also partly
supernatural.
And as you read further into
the grandsons of Clovis,
people whom Gregory himself
has dealings with,
particularly the wayward
Chilperic, you'll see rulers
that Gregory considers to be
evil and rulers who are really
falling away from the example.
But what interests us in our
readings for next week is the
nature of this society.
What's holding it together if
it's rulers are so violent?
Why is it not just falling
apart into fragments and
shattering?
How could this dynasty rule over
a polity for something on
the order of 250 years?
Have fun with the papers, have
fun with Gregory, and we'll
talk next week.
Thanks.